[Music]
do you remember when Pokemon go came out
we were all walking around with our
phones held up to catch Eevee's and
magikarps and Pikachu's wearing Santa
hats it was a good time if your phone
battery could handle it because you know
who doesn't love the idea of exploring
their world for invisible fantastical
creatures for centuries scientists and
explorers have found the same thrill
that games like Pokemon go illicit by
exploring the micro cosmos a very real
universe of organisms that overlays and
intersects with our surroundings but it
is not augmented reality it's actual
reality visible only under a microscope
as we examine samples collected from
locations near and far it's an endeavor
that has taken to some extreme
environments like Antarctica to find
just what kind of microbe can take out a
life and almost to every conceivable
situation but the beauty of the micro
cosmos is that it is everywhere you can
examine a nearby puddle or hike to a
distant lake and there the micro cosmos
will be
[Music]
it's also an incredibly diverse world of
organisms whose contents reflect the
location and chemistry of the area you
select from so the chances are high that
any time you venture out for more
samples something new to you will float
into view under your microscope lens and
before we get to how we collect our
samples let's start with where we get
them from the organisms we showcase on
this channel are all aquatic inhabitants
of water that James our master of
microscopes samples from ponds lakes
aquariums just about any accessible
watery location that seems promising
so how do you figure out whether a body
of water might be a good microbe hunting
ground one indicator to be on the
lookout for is food shallow palms can
accumulate leaves and other plant matter
creating a feast for microbes who
decompose organic matter for their food
on these decomposing leaves you will
often find a thin layer of sediment and
inside that sediment is where you will
find many a microbe here James is using
a transfer pipette to take bits and
pieces of that sediment extracting it
from various points around the decaying
leaves and gathering it into a
collection tube sometimes he uses a
turkey baster instead because sometimes
science requires you know repurposing
other appliances other compelling signs
of life are biofilms a mixture of
microorganisms that have congregated
together into a larger visible mass like
this orange biofilm
it might be a little off-putting to look
out but gross nests at a larger scale
can obscure the beauty of smaller scales
because the area is a bit tough to reach
James adapted another non-scientific
tool for his purposes this time hooking
up a collection tube to a selfie stick
so that he can grab some of that biofilm
for later examination and there are
other tools as well including this
plankton net which is a cone made of
mesh that lets water pass through while
trapping organisms inside our plankton
net has a 20 micron mesh size so as we
pull it out of the water anything larger
than 20 microns will be left behind and
with every drag through the water the
samples become more and more
concentrated with life by the time we're
done our samples will have so many
organisms that they will deplete the
dissolved oxygen in the water very
quickly so when we collect our microbes
in this way we have to check them under
the microscope as soon as possible to
keep them alive there are other signs as
well that a pond or lake might be an
inspiring microbial source like a
greenish color that suggests an excess
of algae but even though the microscopic
life we feature is all aquatic we don't
necessarily have to turn to obvious
bodies of water to find them after all
water is not a guaranteed resource at
all times and a number of microbes have
evolved their own mechanisms to survive
dry spells when water is scarce these
organisms go dormant forming protective
cysts that in case they're resting
bodies until it rains or some other
source of hydration awakens them these
wet/dry cycles can happen over seasons
or just over the course of a day as Dew
forms and then evaporates so while we
might often focus on palms and lakes for
finding microbes it turns out that soil
with its periods of wetness can also
give us some exciting results to find
the micro organisms that live there we
collect the top layer of soil which is
around five centimetres deep we want to
make sure the soil is packed with plenty
of nutrients so we might make sure that
there's a lot of plant litter for the
organisms inside da da
when air-dried these samples can be
stored for years without losing a
significant number of the hardy species
that reside in the soil and when it
comes time to awaken our sleeping
beauties we transfer the soil into petri
dishes and lightly soak them in some
distilled water not too much though we
don't want to flood the soil after 48
hours we will check on the samples by
tilting the petri dish and collecting
some of the water to look at under the
microscope of course these are only a
few of the ways people collect microbes
you might find as you start your own
journey that different settings require
other means like this time James wanted
to see what diatoms ciliates and
flagella --tz-- were living in the
biofilm formed on beach rocks so he had
to scrape at it it is the micro cosmos
after all it just takes a few steps into
nature some simple tools and a little
creativity and the payoff is well it's
tiny but also infinite thank you for
coming on this journey with us as we
explore the unseen world that surrounds
us and thank you of course
and as always to all of these amazing
people whose names are appearing on the
screen right now if you like journey to
the micro cosmos these are the people
who make it possible
they are our supporters on patreon and
you can find out how to join them in the
description if you want to see more from
our master of microscopes James check
out Jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's a
bunch of videos just around the corner
at youtube.com/geekandsundry
you